at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking good oil to your personal
question
now I must have a medic organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton the Tim
Ferriss show is brought to you by on it
I have used on it products for years if
you look in my kitchen in my garage you
will find alpha brain chewable melatonin
for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling kettlebells battle ropes maces
steel clubs
sounds like a torture chamber and it
kind of is it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement and you can see all of
my favorite gear at on it calm the
forward-slash Tim that's onn IT comm
forward slash Tim and you can also get a
discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force I like alpha
bran check it all out on it comm forward
slash Tim the Tim Ferriss show is also
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
your one-stop shop for anything graphic
design related you need a logo you need
a website you need a business card or
anything else you get an original design
from designers around the world who
submit drafts for you to review you are
happy or you get your money back and I
have used 99 designs for book cover
ideas for the 4-hour body which went to
number one New York Times for banner ads
and you can check out some of my actual
competitions at 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim you can also get a
free $99 upgrade if you want to give it
a shot that's 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim
hello ladies gents this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where I deconstruct
world class performers to figure out
what makes them tick and moreover what
are the tools tricks tactics routines
books whatever secret snacks that you
can replicate that you can actually use
in your daily life or in your career or
in your personal endeavors in your
journey into life itself Wow anyway my
guest for this episode is just a
tremendous tremendous man he is an actor
writer director and producer his name is
Jon Favreau I've been hugely impressed
by Jon and we've had an opportunity to
spend some time together he is a man of
many talents he burst onto the acting
scene with his role in Rudy then he
established himself as a writer with the
iconic cult hit swingers in which he
starred and many of you have seen it we
have a lot of stories about swingers
which I was surprised by and I had done
a lot of homework then Favreau made his
feature film directorial debut with made
which also wrote and produced his other
directing credits include Iron Man Iron
Man 2 Cowboys and Aliens elf and that
was a real turning point for him so he
dig into that and I did not know that he
was involved with the elf before I
really dug into it
Zathura and chef which he wrote produced
directed and starred in and the way he
approached making chef was very very
fascinating and as someone who's trying
to create myself in more than one way I
suppose I'm creating books and podcasts
and now TV shows and I have news coming
related to that I was very very
interested in how he approached doing
chef which I fell in love with and
that's actually how I ended up
connecting it was through chef and I
went on Twitter and then we connected
had a short exchange on Twitter and we
also ended up investing in a couple of
startup companies together okay so lots
of commas this guy does everything some
of his recent acting credits include the
wolf of Wall Street and identity thief
and he's done much much more
he is currently directing the live at
Jax
feature film that I'm dying to see
because I'm obsessed with the jungle
book this is Disney's adaptation which
is set to be released in April 2016 so
without further ado I invite you into
the mind and story some of which are
very funny the stories of Jon Favreau
Jon welcome to the show thank you thank
you so much for taking the time I've
really been looking forward to this okay
and I suppose we could start perhaps at
the beginning and one of these questions
that I like to sometimes ask is what
albums or bands you listen to in high
school
what were your go-to what was your go-to
you this one let's see I liked the
earliest music I listened to that I
remember actually had like an album of
was I remember the Animal House
soundtrack all the old music like the
sixties sure music and then Billy Joel I
grew up in New York so Billy Joel and my
first rock album I ever bought was uh
was Led Zeppelin
it was led Zeppelin housing I was in
high school already
mhm and then I was I was in high school
in the 80s so then you had like The
Ramones around in New York and queens
where I'm from so is it it was an
interesting time and then I you know
there's a little bit of overlap with
CBGB's as I got older in high school but
that was more for the scene because it
was cool rather than the music itself
which I don't find myself listening to
too much I ended up getting into Billy
Joel myself I was always a Metallica
sort of heavy metal head and I got him
to Haley Joel because I was a busboy and
waited on him at one point oh really
on Long Island and he was the coolest
guy I'd ever had he would buy a cup of
coffee and give me a twenty as a tip
which was a lot of money right yeah
that's a big that's a good thing to
remember was the other way
yeah that's that's pretty good that's
not and you know in the greater scheme
of things you could probably afford it
but it made it made a big difference
look at that look at huge impression
yeah maybe you made a fan of you still I
still remember that gets remember how
now when a week we may not have the same
exact frame of reference what are you
I'm 48 years old so I'm
ten behind roughly I'm 37 right now so
that was a golden oldie you were listen
to me always right right
I would he was still recording when I
was uh when I was listening to him yeah
he was still I mean everyone the hush
came over all the waitstaff when he came
in yes and Long Island especially oh
yeah kind of absolutely out by Montauk
and the I remember the waiters named
Gavin he was supposed to wait the table
and he said alright I'm gonna do you a
favor today Faris I'm gonna give you
that table because he knew you get
brought out so hard yeah exactly
what was your experience in in high
school what was it like can you paint a
picture high school was um let's see I
was I had just gone to Bronx High School
of Science which was a public school
that you had to take a test for in New
York it was a very good school it had
been around for a while and in the New
York public school system it was was
very good at the time I think it still
is if you're if you do well that you
will never outgrow the public school
system there's always room for people
who are who are you know have you know
who require different education needs on
in every way and I know might my dad was
a public school teacher and and you know
I feel pretty strongly about that system
and especially having lived in other
cities too I really grow to appreciate
it and the Bronx High School of Science
was was one of the flagship schools for
the the that Stuyvesant Brooklyn Tech
you know all of these free schools but I
did have to commute all the way from
Queens to the Bronx was about an hour
and a half each way but I was around
other people who were more academically
inclined but I also met people from
every different borough and all
different walks of life because the you
know the the one thing that the unified
us was that we all passed this test and
and you have a lot of different
socioeconomic backgrounds because again
it was a free school and so I I had the
good fortune of meeting the brightest
from every community so everybody that I
met if I met a kid from Harlem he was
the it was a really smart kid from
Harlem if I my son from Brooklyn from
Riverdale you know so you really had all
of life I didn't realize it at the time
cuz I grew up in New York so diversity
was just something you grew up with
especially as you traveled through
different boroughs you know you just
knew people from all over the place
where if you worked in the city you met
people from everywhere and and you know
that was a I think that was a good
experience too
you learn a little bit I know you're you
you like to speak a lot of languages you
get to know how to curse in every
language right that's usually you pick
up first its Greek and yeah you could do
it in Spanish so but it was seeing a lot
of great kids but there were kind of
nerdy kids they weren't big on sports
teams things like that the long commute
time allotted a lot of homework so I on
the the first thing from high school
that I got into through that crowd was
Dungeons & Dragons that was something I
was really into then I kind of outgrew
that a bit more socially than anything
but I always liked fantasy I always
liked that swords and sorcery stuff and
science fiction and then it then I moved
more into because remember I graduated
84 so it was the early 80s
that's when also punk rock was was kind
of in its heyday and and there were a
lot of clubs downtown that were going
strong that you could go to so and we
were from all the different boroughs so
we were very comfortable going into
Manhattan that was kind of a central
point for this was still in high school
still in high school never really was a
the kids from the city from Manhattan
were more of a a little bit more
socially advanced and could actually get
into these lives here
yeah you know we're we're from the you
know we're the Bridge and Tunnel crowd
so we didn't really end up in the
nightlife too much but but you were
exposed to it and you were going down to
Greenwich Village and hanging out in
Washington Square Park and and and also
that was a lot of when I got introduced
to to cinema because it was pre VCR the
only way you'd see a movie is it was in
the movie theater if it was on
television and so I remember going to a
lot of the revival houses first with my
dad
when I was younger and then and then you
know when I was in high school going on
my own down to like the cinema village
all around all around NYU down there
there were a lot of great revival houses
and seeing the films of like Kurosawa or
say
and just being introduced to a lot of
stuff I would not otherwise have access
to was there any particular film that
was the inflection point for you wanting
to focus on that craft yourself I didn't
want to do it till much later it was
never a realistic option for me so all
the way through high school college it
was never something that I thought I
would do it wasn't till I was 22 that I
actually decided to try an earnest to to
get into entertainment but I always
enjoyed acting and I was loved movies
and I was an usher actually during high
school and an old ex vaudeville house
the RKO keith's and flushing and and as
a as an usher you got to see you know
movies over and over again and it was
still the architecture the projection
room all of it really felt like
something out of a time machine so I you
know was exposed to that side of the
movie business first and and it was you
know it was really cool I liked it I
liked movies it was an old run-down
theater it's not there anymore but it
was really wonderful seeing the he kind
of could see the history of it if you
look behind the curtain because first it
was the old vaudeville palace and then
it started showing films and then and
then eventually I broke it up into a
trip Plex so you had this beautiful
elegant Moorish style just again the
movie palaces of the of the vaudeville
era and the post vaudeville era broken
down into the multiplex is that didn't
have a lot of personality back in the in
the 80s I guess the 70 started that but
it still had some of the gloss of it and
some of the beauty and but you know of
course there were still the dressing
rooms from the vaudeville days and there
were sub basements and he went behind
the the screen and the big theater and
you saw you know all the the ropes and
rigging from its its live theatre days
so it was kind of it was kind of nice
and there was a sense of nostalgia but
it was also just overrun by mice and it
wasn't just it wasn't well maintained so
there was a sadness to it so there was
and this I have a nostalgic feel towards
the movie business even from you know
even from before I was around because I
was exposed to all that stuff and of
course all movies keep
keep the legacy alive as well yeah and
and that was part of the fun part about
coming out here even when I was just
auditioning for the first time for four
bit parts you would audition on the lot
you would go you'd get a drive on and
then you'd be walking around like the
Fox lot see the New York streets or
Warner Brothers and see all the back
Lots as you're walking from your parking
to the appointment and you just felt so
lucky to be in the business you know you
were like um you know I'm somehow
connected to this industry and even
though we were just like the guy
sweeping up after the parade we still
were you know what and give up show biz
you know even the guys shoveling after
the elephant it feels like he's part of
the show and I and I was that guy
and you you dropped out of college is
that right I did yeah it was well
misleading because I took a I took a you
took a lotta left to go to I got a job
offer we got a job offer to work on Wall
Street got it for a friend's dad who
need to hire an assistant and I worked
there for a year
and it wasn't a great fit for me but I
had not been a great student in college
I'd gone to a very academically oriented
high school as I said and then I was on
the waiting list for Cooper Union to go
to school for engineering Cooper Union
is a great school in Greenwich Village
that is it's all scholarship it would
have been a great it would have been a
great fit for me and again my family was
the you know my dad was a teacher so
there wasn't a lot we never a lot of
dough for a private education but the
idea of Cooper Union that would have
gotten a great a great opportunity
waiting list never got called up I ended
up going to Queens College which was a
city school good school too and but
never really found my footing what I
wanted to do was more interested in the
what was going on socially at school
rather than academically I didn't really
have a major I didn't find myself
excelling I got by but um but in Excel
and then after I'd worked for a year and
went back to school then I got Dean's
List straight A's because that that year
of working in the real world really
seasoned me a bit and and I got me I
think matured me a bit and then and then
after I was back in school and back on
the Dean's List that's when I went cross
country
and that's when I discovered people
doing improvisation in Chicago and
decided I wanted to join that circus and
that's when I dropped out got it and the
when you came back and were more
seasoned and hit the Dean's List was
that because of the structure of working
in the adult world or was it because you
saw the benefits of focus rewarded and
say a company or well kind of the
opposite that I felt let that you you at
school if you worked at all you got it
got recognized there's every once a
while an [ __ ] teacher that you know
busting my ass I think I still give him
a bad grades like but that's like a
rarity usually if you're working usually
if you're not doing good in school you
don't like the teacher you're not you're
not coming halfway you're not doing your
job but if you do your work you'll get
an A and there's something real you know
really Galit aryan about that whereas in
the work space you you're expected to
bust your ass and rarely do you get
recognized for the work you do because
somebody else is either they're either
oblivious because they're so hung up on
what they're dealing with your boss or
somebody else's the you know there's
weird office politics or you're just
it's just expected of you to do your
work so it felt like a whiff of reality
of the real world where it's not
revolving around you
whereas in school even if you're part of
a big lecture hall at the end of the day
it's about you you're that you're paying
money to be there they're gonna give you
a grade based on the work you do and
it's focused around how you absorb and
fit the work and how do you fit into the
system in the works play it works based
you're a cog and you can figure out how
to move your way up but it's not
incumbent upon them to recognize you you
have to make your own way so it felt
like a very much it felt like I was
going back to a kinder gentler situation
when I went back to school where I put
in the same work I would have it yet you
know on Wall Street and then I was
getting straight A's so it felt good but
I also felt in another way that it lets
some of the air out of the balloon that
I got a whiff of what real life was what
was waiting in the wings it was kind of
scary that was like okay now I'm gonna
work 50 weeks a
you get two weeks off and I'm gonna live
in those two weeks because pretty much
everything happening during the week
you're either recovering over the
weekends or your or your you know or
your you know you just everything's
about getting ready for work I just came
home from work uh decompressing and just
getting back on the horse the next day
and especially in Manhattan where you're
you know I was commuting from the
borough's also and and and then I had
gone cross-country and seen how
everybody was living and I had what
sparked that cross-country trip I think
it was I think it was that I had worked
for a year right
and I had saved up enough money for a
motorcycle and that was sort of a
fantasy to go he watch like easier at
her house why that's the thing oh man
you know and so I went cross-country and
I was there was a motorcycle rally in
Sturgis South Dakota that happened to be
lining up with when I wasn't in school
or something I don't even remember I've
still it was in school it's going back
many years now in the 80s but I remember
saying oh let me go check this out and
then once I was all the way in South
Dakota a girl I was dating at the time
was in San Francisco and I would look
close on the map let me just close and
that's back when you know she's thinking
about - the other day it was back before
you could just go online and get a map
like you had to belong to like the
Triple A and triptik something where
they would send you maps with
highlighters showing you the route so
you had this map that was like folded up
and you're in your saddle bag and you
would look at it it really was like the
Old West and you know you're like a
horse back going across country and it
was such a long harrowing trip and I
remember how many people in the country
looked like they weren't enjoying
themselves the way they live the way and
some people were having a great time but
like there's there seem to be a lot of
variety in the way people lived and
the lifestyles people had and I think
also having grown up in a big city I
didn't realize what what rural America
was like and really how big the country
was and how how much variety there was
and and also the other thing was how
personable people are and I would you
know here I was on a motorcycle and I
was young and I wasn't you know I was
not user friendly I didn't have the you
know Buckminster Fuller banker look I
was you know a guy climbing all you know
covered with dust and young and New York
plates on my bike and and people were
really cool to me like people really
when if I broke down people helped me
out I helped other people out you know
you sort of develop a sense of how you
fit into the world and how it's not
about you you're one little piece of the
whole thing and you start to appreciate
how big the world is and that you have
to figure out how to fit into that
whereas I think your whole life
especially when I was brought up it's
more about how does it fit into my world
so it's that perspective that you know I
think we all continue to struggle with
as we get older how we fit into this
whole thing how this whole it's not fair
feeling is one that you feel a lot more
when you're young than when you're older
the there's something magical about
motorcycles to being part of the
environment as opposed to inside the the
bubble that is the chassis of the car
yeah would not recommend it by the way
very dangerous I'm not like my buddy is
in a wheelchair now who introduced me to
it it's it fits in really well with your
sense of invulnerability that comes at
that age not something I know I would do
I would thought if I could afford one I
would so let me just say to the people
listening out there I don't want to turn
this into something where I'm
proselytizing for it because it's not
it's not something that I do anymore but
it but it was definitely a bit of a
transcendent experience that you're
flying and you're you are so vulnerable
and so much you know they're you're just
you're just taking it in a much
different way it's it's like a ride so
I'm going to love to ask you about
Chicago
motorcycle also just as a side note for
folks I totaled the bike and at that
point sold it because I had a friend get
fantastic rider get had a car run a red
light hit him at an intersection cut off
one of his legs and when your body is
the bumper my mom actually calls
motorcycles and donor cycles because
she's been a PT for its 30-plus year
reign injuries with perfect organs so
and it's not that it's not the rider
it's the people around you yeah and and
and under the right circumstances it's
great but the way I'm very fortunate
that that I made it out intact because
it's it's bad odds plant your plan
you're playing slots
it's not it's not the best yeah it has
nothing to do with how good you are as a
rider like he said it's definitely back
the clock a little ways so I won't spend
too much time in this but I was a runt
up until about sixth grade got the
living hell beat out of me all the time
and D&D was my refuge alright so I still
have all of my modules I'm one of those
guys now I'm completely self-conscious
about the fact that I played it's like
takes a lot for me to talk freely like
this about it but I feel a weird shame
why why do you feel I feel this I kind
of wear it as a badge of honor in a way
because I've run into so many people who
also had that shared experience I think
I've grown into it like I think I'm
accepting of it now but it was such a
way I had been to define myself for the
first few years like for like a freshman
and sophomore year in high school and
that was like what and then when I
didn't do it anymore you're so quick to
say yeah because I find that there's
nothing more embarrassing than whatever
the last phase you just went through was
it continue to feel that way yeah you
know thank God my life is not you know
all the things that had ways you
embarrass yourself all the haircuts
you've had the ways that you dress the
music you guys never rat tail exactly is
and now you know I'm of the age where
you know for the the children's
generation of this age that's all going
to be well-documented very hard to
receive okay every single Facebook you
know picture you put up will be there on
some level so but but I you know you're
right I think that there was a
tremendous value in it I have an
affection for it I remember too much of
it you know it really took up a lot of
my brain space when I was when I was
around that age whatever fifteen or
fourteen I forget what age I was playing
but it also created a set of I think it
I think it encouraged a set of skills
that is not that unlike filmmaking
because you're telling a story and the
people who are experiencing that story
especially if you're like a dungeon
master you're telling the story in a way
that with the people who are
participating who've signed on our
experience in a very subjective way and
there appears to be a certain level of
spontaneity or freewill and there is
built into it but you're creating a
context in a world and experience that's
very specifically curated so you're
guaranteeing a sort of experience
regardless of what they do within it I
think when you're watching movies the
the the illusion is that you're you're
you're subjectively experienced in the
film as an individual and you're kind of
making those decisions in a de facto way
through the character that you're
following the film through if a
character in a film ever makes a
decision that the audience doesn't feel
that they agree with it changes the
experience it becomes like a horror
movie where don't go in that room you
know it becomes a much different type of
experience or you're if you're watching
a character that's um that's not you
know that you're watching because
they're they're an antihero you know
when you're watching Travis Bickle is a
different experience than most films
because most films you're going to walk
through it experience the things that
the characters do they're gonna do a
smarter version usually if something you
would have done and they're going to be
facing a lot of consequences and you're
rooting for them because you and them
are kind of riding next you're the
copilot of the protagonist and and in
role-playing games there's it's a
similar experience but but a different
medium
were you did you have a particular race
of preference for you a dwarf a all
those I didn't like the elves so much I
liked the dwarves like the hobbits I was
always a grey elf though where you know
that makes sense for it for you I don't
remember what's the grey is a great
different just I I like the good ones
yeah they're also draw I think it was
the Dro elf those were the dark elves at
Dark One's they they were the I remember
more from the Tolkien's stuff yeah it
sort of replaced it because I was
invaded as they do they do blend
together they do well yeah we were very
close but I like The Hobbit because I
read the book The Hobbit and before I
ever played the game it was an important
book to me and I always like I kind of
relate to the to that character because
he just wants to be comfortable and
living in like the nice environment but
then it's drawn out into the adventure
and then returns it's very Joseph
Campbell that that reluctant hero and I
think that that's a good metaphor for
for what I've experienced is that the
you know I've never jumped into the
stuff you know I guess I guess you may
be there's been a little bit of boredom
or unrest and earlier in my life but but
generally I kind of like I I like some
kind of things kind of boring
but then every once in a while I just
there's a little bit of that that
adventure blood in me that forces me out
of it I think we're different people
from reading knowing you have more
self-preservation instinct towards
complacency or something but I do it
kind of in spite of who I am as opposed
to because I'm I have this wanderlust
and I and I can't sit still I just get
bored sometimes and I want variety or I
get something captures my fancy and I
get really curious and want to try
something new I'm an only child I tend
to do it more from me I find then to
show other people I tend to be very what
is the itch that you're scratching with
that that that novelty satisfies do you
think I don't know you know I think it's
different as I get older because now it
becomes about what impressions I had
from younger in life and things you know
on that checklist
of you know people by the car that they
never could afford sure later or they
you know where they date the girl they
couldn't date you know there's a sense
of somehow you know working on your
scorecard but for me it's like like I
want as I get older especially it's like
I wanted to try to sculpt and I and I
started school literally yeah yeah
literally like sculpting and I'm lucky
that I work with such talented people of
all different diverse skill sets and the
movie business then when I want to
sculpt I talk to somebody who's an
expert sculptor sculptor and they and
they put together a little package for
me of and a list of tools I need and
next thing you know without a lot of
wasted time I'm sculpting I was drew
yeah and I always would sculpt a little
bit here and there whatever if I was in
like a class or playing with the kids
play-doh and daddy was always good at
making it step aside kid you know when
you go parent-teacher day or whatever
the kids would bring that to school
whatever that thing is when Danny could
make something cool out of play-doh you
get you get you know respect or some
schools ready yeah
so what material were you or are you
using on now Siobhan something called
sugar ponch is one of those like I think
it's petroleum-based or wax based clays
that doesn't dry and you have to heat up
to get it so you have these blocks that
are kind of like plastic I suppose
that's kind of I know you're talking
about yeah and it was developed I think
for the automotive industry so you get
some really nice textures out of it and
it's just fun to do because you you're
doing better than you thought you could
now why sculpture as opposed to I wanted
to be a color quote penciler for about
ten years so I did a lot of illustration
why why the sculpture as opposed to
something else like watercolors sir oh
because I know there's something fun I
did it because you could give it to
people yeah okay it's like a thing it's
like a substantial thing that you have
or you could display or you could give
or or cast into a metal or I don't know
it just seemed kind of cool
I was I was messing around on the
set a jungle book with we had blocks of
wax because there's a sequence where
that we have big beehives that we had to
cast and we had to cast it out of wax so
it interacted in a way that was
realistic and so we had blocks and
blocks of beeswax around and so while I
was on the set on the many hours sitting
at the in the director's chair
I had a block of wax sitting there for
about a month and then next thing you
know I I asked for something to carve it
with it it carved it with and I got like
some little carving tools next thing I
was carving a bear and next thing you
know I feel like I pull over the all
these artists that are working on this
oh well what's how how's Shh well the
better the ears are a little far back
move this a little fan says getting
pointers and in everybody who passed by
well looks like a bear yeah
so it's it's a little bit oh what a good
boy am I and something of to see at this
age honestly it's like I'm very happy to
be working in the field than I am I feel
like I'm learning constantly but I
understand why I think like Nick Nolte I
hurt like loves glassblowing like I get
it I get why that's exactly the type of
thing to be doing and I did actually my
experience was with cooking with you I
read your book by the way I know I've
told you this but let me tell you this
on me I appreciate that as the 4-hour
chef when I was preparing to do chef I
always liked watching which blew my mind
I've said it to you and I've said it's
on the Internet's but just we're gonna
dig into that okay lovely movie thank
you it was a great movie an important
film for me because it it just you know
it allowed me to deal with themes that I
felt were important but but also it gave
me the excuse to learn from great chefs
and work in the kitchens of great chefs
to prepare for the acting in in the film
and I loved cooking I loved and I never
really the the the chef who really was
was my partner in this as he was
preparing me when when we first started
he said you know you a chef when a chef
cuz you telling me these things to teach
me but also to understand insight as I
told the story to make the film one that
he and the community would like he said
when a chef sees a bag of shallots they
get excited because they're gonna get to
peel all the shallots
and and which I thought was it was
confusing at first but then after going
through the culinary training everything
there's some it's true there's something
very meditative about preparing your
mise and plus because you you're dealing
with sharp implements and you have to
get it perfect and you can't hurt
yourself and you can't really do
anything but this thing but it doesn't
require all of your brain at the same
time and so you get into this really
cool zone where you
everything's so thoughtful that you're
doing and by the time you actually
prepare a meal with all of this means
that you prepare that you that you get
ready there's a tendency to be very
tuned in to what you're tasting or what
you're presenting to your guests because
they know the work they've been watching
you put work into it and so the
mindfulness that it implies and and and
demands and it's preparation but it also
asks of the people who you're sharing it
with it creates a nexus point of all the
people where you're all sharing a common
experience at one moment which is
something I've grown to appreciate and
and it's a very elusive dynamic as a dad
it's very you know being very very
present as you you know spend time with
your kids making sure you're not
checking your emails when you're tucking
the kids in you know it's and and with
friends and as a husband there's a it's
not something I did effortlessly a
decade ago and it's something that I've
grown into and I find that people as
they mature they they start to value
that more and so everything I look to do
whether it's sculpture or you know I
would be a glassblower I would love to
play with that it seems fascinating or
you know any of these hobby type things
or the cooking is all about being very
present in that moment and and it's a
good it's a good counterbalance to the
intensity with which I approached my the
work that I do I think the the word
mindfulness is so
appropriate for cooking and I found that
the what used to create so much stress
such a stretch response to me which was
preparing food has now become like you
said almost this meditative practice
where I could meditate in the mornings
and I tend to do that but I also find
that if I just make food make dinner two
or three times a week and you have these
knives so you have to be present state
where it's it has a tremendous
decompressing effect are there any
particular ingredients that you're
playing with these days or anything like
I've ever since I made chef and met
Aaron Franklin down in Austin
I've been over and over again refining
my smoked brisket the Central Texas self
smoked brisket and to me that's like
alchemy you know it's it's there's
there's a certain amount of technique
and the trimming and in the way you but
mostly it's about leaving alone it's
almost like baking in that way like it's
it's it's it's chemistry and changing
little factors but it's taking whatever
it is fourteen hours to see how it turns
out there's something really rewarding
about that and it's also a flavor that
people don't get anywhere else so when
you do it right and people get to taste
it it's it's kind of a fun it's kind of
a fun thing to share because it's
special and it's only it's only good for
a short amount of time - yeah it's you
know it's like coffee and then it kind
of goes away yeah
and then I like that I like um simple
pasta dishes very simple ones you know
like there's a there's a pasta Scarpetta
the restaurant Scarpetta makes a really
good pasta that's just animate Oh sauce
that you could find online the recipe
for but it but making the pasta from
scratch infusing the oil starting the
tomato sauce from roma tomatoes that you
blanch and peel and slow cook and mash
down into a sauce and then mixing it
with the infused olive oil and then
cooking that with the pasta water and
getting the right texture and again it's
amazing but it's only good for just a
few minutes and and then and then with
the pasta dish is great cuz you you pull
together a group of people who are
interested in doing it it's a great
thing to do if the family's all
vacations
sir you're over at a relative's house
especially cuz I have less and less
things to talk about as my my context is
so different from everybody else's that
you know if we talk about movies it's
not you know I'm thinking about the
other things than the people talking we
were thinking about and you know it's
there's so little overlap with most
people that I meet that cooking is great
because it creates this context where
everybody is on equal footing and
everybody has a different skill set and
it becomes a real a task that you have
to be in your interdependent with and it
it I finally have endless patience to
spend time with people that I don't know
very well if you're working on a really
cooking project and at the end we all
serve it together and we really feel
like we fought a war together it's a
great it's a great bonding thing I'm
working on a kitchen at my in my house
that's geared towards having like groups
of people cook that feels more like a
restaurant style big tabletops yeah and
all like open shelving and you know
everything that you'd see you know
beautiful and aware restaurants
beautiful not beautiful for a house but
but the people who like to cook it's
it's like the perfect like like a lab
and it's it's fun because you know
you're all gathered around and and I did
it my experience the first time I did it
like that was at the at the Skywalker
Ranch which is where we we mix the sound
for a few movies I've been working with
them I think since Iron Man but for
those who don't know it's it's a it's a
five thousand acre ranch in Northern
California in Marin that George Lucas
put together and and and oversaw the
architecture for and it's a started off
as just a sound facility very Heights
very it looks very low-tech it looks
like a winery almost but beautiful
rolling hills with cattle grazing
Victorian house on the hill that he's
that where he does his editing and where
he uses his his home base and other
technical buildings that have cropped up
around it and it's state of the art
mixing facility sound facility recording
stages
so it's this very strain and in a bunk
house with themed rooms for the people
who who work there because you you stay
there when you work there because it's
so remote and so each room is themed for
either a director or writer and see how
like the John Ford room that's
western-themed akira kurosawa room
dorothy parker room and so you stay
there and during the day there are
restaurants that are opened on the
facility at night everything closes down
but there's a commercial kitchen in the
common area and a walk-in a walk-in
fridge and so as we were making chef you
know you're looking at these scenes over
and over and listening to the crackling
of the you know the frying food and the
the pasta and the olive oil and the the
garlic
simmering and your mouth watering all
day and each night we would pick another
recipe from the movie and all of us me
and the editors the sound crew we'd all
get together and we cook together at
night and we cook all the dishes from
the movie and it was so much fun because
here were in the middle of you know in
the middle of nowhere really in a very
remote spot and and just together you
know the fireplace going all of us
cooking together and you sit down for
the meal and you sleep good and then we
hit it the next morning and we would do
the next real sounds like a hell of a
hell of a routine it was very amazing it
was really wonderful so that's what I
want to try to see if I capture some of
that at home yeah the the one thing
that's always struck me about a
well-designed kitchen it's just the
elegance and the economy of movement
that it provides for a chef where
they're there they're never reaching too
far for anything everything I mean you
have everything in its place or at the
Mesa and placer and how quickly a good
line cook or chef can work if they have
all their items in the right place yeah
it's true it's it's it's interesting
because I did part of the training I did
was work in first first I went to some
pretty accelerated culinary training
that Roy sent me to off with a French
chef to get the context before I ever
entered a professional kitchen and so I
went through all my mother sauces and my
knife cuts and basically an overview of
what the first year culinary students
would deal with
then I got to come into his kitchens he
has a few different restaurants and food
trucks too and I spent time floating
from restaurant to restaurant first they
let me like prep cook so I was picking
parsley and you know I mean I've done
that micro basil yeah there you're
holding up my station first oh my god I
guess all that trust you with and it's
so like labor-intensive and so you
finally do that and then then eventually
I work my way up to the hot line and on
the hot line then I started working and
then and then I worked the pretty by
midway through I started working on one
of his Kogi trucks and it reminded me
because the air you're in tight quarters
to you reminded me very much of
bartending which is what I did to make a
living in college and after college when
I moved to Chicago as a bartender and
you know there's that dynamic of getting
in the weeds it's kind of halfway
between being a chef and being a server
because you're preparing things but
you're also dealing with the public and
you're not doing anything that
complicated so you don't have the
there's not the elegance of being a chef
at least the type of bartender I was I
wasn't like a mixologist like you see
now but but there is this you do get
into the weeds and you have to do this
dance with the people in a very small
space and I found that that rhythm was
coming back to me as I was working
especially on that truck well you know
how to get the way you pop in you pop
out you reach around on somebody's left
on their right you're behind them you're
not crashing into each other and you're
helping each other out you becoming like
this big octopus together and when
you're working on the hot line it's even
more that way because there's you know
behind you you know there's like hot
food coming through people speaking
different languages you're you're being
asked to do things you're being
instructed to that's the other weird
thing it's not like they prepare you
ahead of time and say here's how you
make everything let's train maybe when
you first open a restaurant it's that
way but when you're working in an
established kitchen they basically just
throw you on the line and then the rush
comes and and then they show you once
how to do something and then you just
copy them and maybe they show it to you
again
and then the chef's watching you from a
distance and saying hey you only put
mayo on one side of the bonnet goes I'm
both you know there's a certain
quality control aspect that the chef's
that's really what the chef's job is is
overseeing other people doing the work
and keeping the standards to a certain
consistency and so there was you know
working and little by little you know
first its I'm just doing the popcorn at
a frame and then then I'm next you know
I'm pulling the burgers out or doing the
you know assembling some sandwiches and
next thing you know I'm plating and next
so by the end of the Saturday dinner
rush you know there's a half dozen
plates I'm helping with and you start to
appreciate how good these other people
are you know that people who work the
broiler or the saute cook you know who
the grill station is just nailing them
you know making it perfect and timing it
just right and then and then the one
that I remarked that the most was the
was the was the Busboys who knows just
went to walk up to you with that with
that deli container full of ice water
and like that's that best water you've
ever had like I even know I was thirsty
and then this guy hands me this like 16
hours you know the quart size like you
get wonton soup in that right leer
container so those are all over kitchens
right those with deli containers and
they they'll give you one full of ice
water and you'll drink it in like one
sip and it's the best thing I've ever
had in your life and and as I was
mentioning that to Roy he says yeah
you're ready to make the movie that's
how you have that that experience is
what how I know you're ready
so speaking of moments when did you
decide to write chef I'd love to talk a
little bit about the writing process
chef chef Liz okay so I remember I you
know it's kind of hard out of context
with with what the swingers experience
was sure kind of weaker is that we can
about well let's talk about both so with
swingers it was um that I had I had not
known I was gonna be a writer had
received from my dad final draft which
was a program that is pretty user
friendly and in formats you're writing
to look like a screenplay and and and
for people who are writers want to be
writers a lot of it is there are subtle
things that looks like a let's say a job
like a resume for a job there are
certain standards by how you're going to
put that together so that when some
receives that resume it looks
professional the formatting the
formatting all that stuff I don't know
that much about just regular jobs but
but I know like a lot of effort goes
into the resume a headshot for an actor
for a screenplay as people receive the
script they're making a lot of little
subconscious calculations and decisions
about you based on what they're seeing
and a screenplay that's not formatted
properly is something that's completely
dismissed and what was fun was when I
received the program I just typed a
little bit next thing I know it looked
just like a real screenplay and I've
read enough of them from being an actor
and this was after I had already done
Rudy I had moved to Los Angeles I
thought that was gonna be my big break
but things weren't really popping for me
but I had read enough scripts and knew
enough about acting to feel comfortable
tapping away the screenplay never
thinking it was been anything was gonna
happen with it more to show my friends
and you know you type you type for a
half hour an hour two hours next thing
you know you got like a stack of eight
pages and it feels like you've got a
piece of a screenplay there so then it
becomes like I just want to try this you
know it kind of goes back to the earlier
conversation we're having about why why
do you why do you do things you know for
you it's that you can't sit still and
you're it's part of there and you're
super curious and you got a lot of
energy and you you kind of hunger for it
I think with me it's it's it's a little
bit more erratic than that where I just
get I just get some bites me in the ass
and I want to try something like I'm
just curious about something if I could
do something but it's um it's much
subtler and I just tap away at it and
peck away at it and then it starts to
look good and as it looks better you
start to build up like with doing
sculpture like messing around a little
bit next thing you know how it kind of
looks like a bear well let me carve it a
little bit better let me try a little
bit more let's see how far I could take
this thing and and so with the
screenplay it was kind of like that and
showed it some friends showed it to the
acting agent I had people felt good
about the swingers screen playing and me
how long did it take you to get it to a
first draft let's just say very fast
because there's no pressure I didn't
have any and in happening I would I
would outline maybe a few pages ahead of
where
I came from an improv background from
Chicago so it's really just characters
talking to each other the improv that I
did was something called The Herald
which was Adele close it invented it was
a great improv teacher and Herald The
Herald okay like the name okay got it it
was one of those things like what do you
call it Harold you know it was one of
those that's how it got its name like
The Beatles haircut I think I got it had
a name I forget what the name was but
but there's it's long form so you would
start off and take one suggestion and do
three different scenes with different
characters that were unrelated all
inspired by this one suggestion and then
you would have three beats of those
scenes and by the end they would all
interweave and connect and come to some
greater statement about the the the
suggestion than just a short form joke
oriented improvisational skit would so
it's looking to bring improv into
revealing as a higher form to reveal
greater truths about about the
suggestion by forming group mind with a
team of improvisers who are used to
working with one another that was the
aspiration for that but it did give me a
set of skills having done that in
Chicago for a while that you know your
self editing your you knowing when each
scene should end you're bringing the
next scene to begin maybe after some
time has passed or with a plot point
that had occurred and you know you're
learning story you're learning story the
hard way you're learning the story in
front of a bar full of people who paid
four dollars to be in there and they
want to be entertained and laugh but the
laughter doesn't last if there's no
story stories the king and you know you
think it's about the last but really
it's about investing in the story being
drawn in and and so I I guess I had
enough skills from that and also read
enough screenplays and maybe the
Dungeons & Dragons and stuff of being a
storyteller knowing how to create a
little bit of a world that you know here
here I was unfolding the story about
this group of friends and Hollywood set
in the same world I lived in I had
broken up or been broken up with at the
I'm about a year earlier so still that
was fresh in my mind so that was one of
the characters dilemmas and you know
though wasn't really
autobiographical there were enough
things that I could draw from you know
what's the expression from Glengarry
Glen Ross always tell the truth it's the
easiest thing to remember yeah draw a
punt you know if you're gonna talk about
neighborhood talk about the neighborhood
you grew up and talk about the
neighborhood you know even if it's not
you but you're gonna have a more
consistent world that you're developing
then if you're putting them on Mars and
you don't understand Mars so you know a
lot of things got slugged in and and I
wrote it for it fairly quickly about two
weeks two weeks it was very quick and it
didn't change really that much after
that did not change did not but I'd
remember I've written my sketches and
things did you write it start to write
it but you wrote it from the beginning
to the end beginning in a few things
change not much 10% kind of over time
and that was in final draft yeah yeah
there's a good was chef the same way
that you did it start to finish so chef
I didn't you know I'd written made after
that few years later and then I had been
hired as a writer based on swingers to
do script doctoring and things and
that's where it gets tough because when
you start getting paid to do something
that used to do for fun you don't want
to do it for fun as much and and what
was nice about it is that you can you
could make a living enough to you know
for a single dude to be able to buy a
house over a few years and you know
drive a new car you know or new ish car
but you can make a living just being a
writer for hire because they're always
looking for people with fresh takes and
new ideas in the writing area because
the very established writers are all you
know they're busy you know you get hired
to do one thing that could keep you busy
for a year so there's always room for
another writer once you kind of make
that list unfortunate if you're not on
the list you can't get in the door and
swingers put you on the list swingers
put me on that list so I went from an
actor and also people kind of knew me
from my acting from Rudy and so there's
a bit of a novelty of being an actor
that they recognize and know and you're
already used to being in those rooms
you're already people know who you are
you know who they are you already have
representation so it's easier to get
into that system
so that was a bit of a I wouldn't say
it's a life hack but but it's a am I
using that term properly I think I think
I think that you trying to sound like I
fit on your podcast here oh you already
fit on the podcast you're doing great
the I think the the it seems like you
gave yourself sort of more tickets in
the raffle so to speak than a lot of
people because you had the writing
acting directing well irons in the fire
not not all in the sir that's not
ventually but in the beginning remember
I'm trying to break into another field
right right so I'm like seeing how far I
could take this thing and the acting
thing got me more raffle tickets in that
sense but it was an interesting way into
writing and much like how acting was a
really interesting way into directing
because in directing one of the
disadvantages that most people other
than me had was that if you're going to
direct the only way you can show people
your director is by directing there's no
apprenticeship per se and directing it's
not like assistant directors there's an
apprenticeship you could work your way
up from way up from a PA work your way
up to second second second ad to first
ad you will hit the top of the food
chain
and by learning from other people who
are better than you there's no room on
the set for another the directors
assistant is not another director the
directors assistant is somebody who was
a PA somebody who worked in development
somebody who's you know most I don't
think I've ever met a director whose
assistant was was a director in training
and even then you're not getting that
experience but as an actor I got to have
front-row seats for every director that
I worked with so by the time I ever
directed I already you know there were a
half-a-dozen directors that I thought
were great and half a dozen I thought
weren't great and I emulated the ones
that were great and being an actor
you're kind of modeling yourself
imitating what the people you respect do
and that's kind of what musicians do too
right if you you know you everybody
mrs. Hendrix licks first and then they
come up with their own style but there
is a there is a this mimicking phase of
learning and and it's tough to get those
10,000 hours under your belt just by
going to film school now maybe it's
different because now people can
literally take a camera go out film
something edit it put it up get feedback
see if people like it or they don't and
they could hit the drawing board again
it does not cost hundreds of thousands
of dollars they can they can do that
thanks to technology but time I was
coming up that wasn't that wasn't even
an option swingers was done as cheaply
as you possibly could for that quality
of a film and that was almost two
hundred thousand dollars and clerks had
been done even cheaper than the budget
was $200,000 a hundred and seventy five
something like that but clerks have been
done for I think ten thousand or
something ridiculous like that and
that's a you know that's a feat done at
a time when it wasn't quite that
straightforward it was very inspiring uh
it wasn't before we had done it and
we're like why can't we just do it
because instead of trying to sell
swingers we ended up making ourselves so
by the time I had done chef was like I
had been wanting to do something
everything I was developing I was trying
to work as a chef into because I wanted
to be something I want to learn about so
if I was working on a TV pilot or
working on a developing something for
his producing something for somebody
else it was like though what about in a
restaurant what about chef because it
seemed like it was a very from watching
Top Chef and following chefs reading
chefs biographies reading Kitchen
Confidential which is the first one that
I read by Bourdain great book great book
and it seemed like there's something
here but it didn't seem like something
that warranted its own I couldn't see
the way to make it into its own thing so
that was kind of bubbling around my head
and then something about by doing
something about being a dad being we're
talking my mindfulness about mindfulness
and parenting about how a few simple
overseeing a few important things in
your life over the course of many years
can ruin your life
if you don't invest enough into the the
things that are important but not
pressing so if you put everything into
your career or not into the things that
won't
things that aren't the squeaky wheel but
are important but not in the short term
over time you'll find yourself in the in
a situation you don't even understand
hey you got into you know when you see
it a lot in the chef well just a lot in
the movie world a lot of fail if
families that where it doesn't work out
and a lot of it's because the the career
demands so much time so much effort and
creating that balance which which you
know fortunately I've done you know the
the older I get the better I get at it
and and and now things are you know I
think well balance for me but I want to
make something about somebody where they
weren't well balanced what if I had made
different decisions in my life early on
and and then looking at it through the
idea of the culinary world and and
having really the stories about growth
spurts it's about right coming-of-age
I'm a big I mentioned Joseph Campbell's
monomyth yeah I'm sorry oh no I was
saying just the bottom if I finally
ended up just a mono mono LCD talks
about I've become fascinated by Joseph
Campbell in the last few years
also the the how these archetypes right
uh translate across all cultures and
indigenous tribal herewith thousand
philology exactly yeah
you ever seen speaker Skywalker that I
think the first time I ever saw the
Skywalker Ranch was on the power of myth
with Joseph Campbell's interviewed by
Bill Moyers oh I haven't seen out I
haven't that's one of the first when
when video first came out that was one
of the first things that was uh
available in that realm and it still
holds up it's great
I'm sure it's easy to get your hands on
the power of meth and he's being he's in
sitting in the library at the Skywalker
Ranch being interviewed of everything
back for you know from Adam and even
earlier all the way through Star Wars
and it's like a four-part or six-part
series from PBS I think it was great
that was my introduction to to Joseph
Campbell and then there's books about
relating that archetype rise of the hero
storytelling two screenplays and how
there's less variation than you might
think and the more you stick to it the
better it's just is it's it's those are
great instruments to fly with and with
Jungle Book I really
you know going back and doubling down on
that on just going back to the to the
old myths and it works so well for for
Lucas oh yeah I mean it's I've been I'm
fascinated by screenwriting and I
haven't spent a lot of time looking at
the format but I took the story seminar
by McKee and have read a handful of
books that's pretty intense
yeah that is that is intense its intense
I've ever gotten all the way through I
found it very dense I found it difficult
there handful of others like save the
cat that I found very helpful for me
personally just to think about the
storytelling mechanisms there's one
called if I may of course the writer's
journey the writers during the writers
journey and I I'm sorry I'm a loss I
could look it up won't work while we're
talking I'll put it in the show notes as
well okay you'll put it in oh yeah right
because what it does is it takes Joseph
Campbell and refines it down from the
perspective of somebody think it was a
story executive at Disney and and and
breaks what breaks apart what that what
those archetypes are and how they apply
to movies that you would have seen
breaking down movies using that and and
also talking about three act structure
as it is a as it pertains to the the
mythic structure that Campbell talked
about with the the calling the refusal
of the call the entering into the
extraordinary world the entering the
inmost cave the killing the dragon
taking the elixir going back and healing
the land and even back when i ieave
unless i had already read the book by
the time I had done swingers and looked
at swingers oh the register and it's
been arrived early it's been around for
a while and I had remember reading that
book and seeing if it if I was
structurally correct with swingers and
and I was satisfied that I was but the
trick I think is not to use it as a map
to write because you have to write I
think you just have to brain dump when
you're right I don't think you could try
to control your writing too much
for me some people are very different
people who come out of you know where
they're creating series arcs for a
television show it becomes you know you
have to develop a group mind and you
could use the dry erase board and you
plot things out it may change but it's
very well thought through and and I find
that people that have come from that
background tend to like to outline a lot
and then there are other people who just
come from prose and creative writing or
you know stories you know short story
writers that where they just want to you
know the routine has more to do with
what time of day they write how much
coffee they have before they do you know
getting into that you know getting into
the creative routine that's where their
structure is there's only some form of
structure sometimes the structures in
the writing some of our structures in
the writing the act of writing but I
found I find that for me I like to do I
like to outline a little bit I like to I
first to do so so here's what you
getting back to chef so with chef I
those two thoughts of wanting to write
something about the chef world and want
to do something about mindfulness and
parenting both crashed into each other
and I got the idea the Epiphany hit me
that that I this is this could all come
together in a project let me write this
thing and I and I took out I like
composition I know you like the minutiae
I do I love the minutiae so composition
mean composition notebooks you know the
black and white flex cover cardboard
sure sewn spine looks kind of like a
zebra the black and white on the cover
exactly I like those because they find
anything answer my drawing days when I
used to get like a really nice
leather-bound drawing paper sketch book
I'd be so reluctant to to defile it yeah
like is this drawing good enough for my
because it would always felt like a
showpiece whereas the the notebooks seem
like because everybody grew up with them
like is their first notebook that
there's a freedom and marking it up but
you can't rip pages out right so you
can't self edit because if you do the
book falls apart so it's not like a
spiral he can use this about for me he
can use a spiral
so I have for everything I've done and
there's a lot of incomplete projects
I'll get a composition notebook I'll
date it title it and then just start
filling it with some time
stream-of-consciousness sometimes a list
of movies that I want to look at that
relate to this a book image something
and it becomes my you know that's where
I board just brain dump and so for chef
I was actually meditating I was
meditating and the two things hit each
other and usually if I'm meditating
which I try to do at least once a day
know that I don't always but it I find
that in part of the distraction of
meditating creative thoughts might pop
into my head but that seems to be a
distraction so I have to push past those
it's it's kind of like on the highway
entrance first you have everything
you're worried about hit you then you
start to have creative thoughts that are
interesting and spiring but those will
those will trick you into not meditating
too so like these are all obstacles that
you have to kind of pass by and then and
then you get into the the good part if
there's such a thing I know you're not
supposed to judge it or think about it
any but but you get into that brain wave
or whatever that that thing is it seems
to be the experience that that when you
meditate that you that you seek that
kind of baseline thoughtless my try to
fill the void sort of loading in the
void I don't if I get as far as the void
but I mean that time I feel but yeah
that's good I don't know if I'm that
good how do you meditate what type of
meditation just you know do you focus on
your breath do you focus on something
like that that TM or breath or I try
different things but now you know
honestly it's like I don't even it's
it's it's it's more of like an exercise
now like I know how to get to I think
it's a it might be a brainwave pattern I
don't know but it's a state of mind that
I can hit without really tricks I kind
of just need to take me about
for six minutes and I could get there do
you sit in a chair with your feet on the
floor or you like folded I try to lay
down as you fall asleep right yeah but I
try to do that I used to do it I haven't
found a place and ever it's nice when
you could do at the same time every day
I just switched from production to
post-production on this so no I don't
haven't gotten into my routine I've been
doing it as much as I should
otherwise I'd like to but but in the
middle of it I got the the idea for chef
hit me and I let myself stop which I
don't usually do and I took out a pad
and I just scribbled out like eight
pages of ideas and thoughts and I left
it alone and then read it and it had you
know if I look back on it and read those
pages it really had 80% of a heavy
lifting done as far as what it was about
who was in it who the characters were
what other movies to look at what the
tone is what music I would have in it
what type of food he was doing I did the
food truck and the Cuban sandwiches and
Cuban music and and he's from Miami and
and so it all sort of grew out from that
and then I went ahead and I have enough
half written screenplays that I just
forced myself to keep writing every day
and so this only took me a few weeks to
to get the first draft but the big thing
was I was so scared of it's like the
Kubla Kahn dream the poem Kubla Kahn
right it wasn't that the story that it
was a dream and only part of it was
written out because you forgot it all
the poet I think I have that I hate I
think I have that right going back to
school I don't remember the details
right but the idea that sometimes you
feel like when you're writing a story or
screenplay if you let enough time pass
in the first draft you get off of that
that kind of get out of the zone on your
own yeah because I don't think it's
something you control I think it's
something you access and I don't think
I'm not not to say it's from some other
mystical place but whatever that part of
your brain that it comes from is a is
not a part of your brain that you
necessarily can force to do what you
want it's not do not fully to
to get it right yeah you gotta kind of
you got to kind of trick it into doing
its thing and when you did the the brain
dump it down into the composition
notebook
do you take then I'd imagine these are
not necessarily in chronological order
it's just a full-on brain you know some
of its chronological then you go back
and hit another part of it and then run
it through again and so it does it does
go on little tears it's like a pitch
session except you're alone and when you
said tone what would be an example of
tone for a movie how you should write
that down or discuss like each ranked
man woman opening like yes that stuff
right fantastic
big night you know a lot of it's movies
a lot of it is what a Vista Social Club
soundtrack food truck food Cuban
sandwiches Cuban sandwiches the Sun the
there's a divorce the they've been
separated but they get along get along
and he's with he's stuck he's with he's
there's a critic coming yeah this is it
this brat to Tullius there's only so
many there's only so many cooking
restaurant movies you can make and the
guy is preparing these goes to the
farmers market and brings his kid with
him like so there's there's moments
there's vignettes there's images and
some of them are sequences and some of
them are movies and sometimes it's
movies that are in your memory and then
when you see the movie it's not that but
it's the version in your head from what
you remember of a movie and then you and
then Kitchen Confidential I remember
referencing that a lot and and who the
characters are and I wanted very a lot
of Latino cast members because that's
what was really Kitchen Confidential I
remember like that's really what
kitchens were and what I saw and what it
was and never what was depicted and how
does that the the how does the vibrance
of that culture with the music playing
in the kitchen and then there cooking
food that's not that and then in being
re inspired he's inspired by that who
the people that are surrounding him the
music he's listening to
and where he came from in Miami and
maybe that's the type of food he used to
cook and I was cooking very trendy you
know user friendly food that wasn't
inspiring to him and and then being
frustrated by not being inspired by his
his art is no longer inspiring him and
he's hit an impasse and they also at the
impasses affecting both his professional
life but in a way he's not aware of his
personal life - he's stuck
spiritually stuck and on the on the show
business side of things this is
something I know very little about but
in terms of the the the actual making
selling distributing of the film and
feel free to correct me if I get this
wrong what I've heard you refer to I
think making chef as going back to
basics and sort of constraining the size
or the budget so that you could do
certain things like have the language
you wanted to have in the movie for
instance be authentic how did you make
this movie and I know that's a very
novice question but I've talked to
people sort of indirectly you've gone
through the big studio process and have
had a very rough time of it what made
chef different how did you were swingers
you could come in on on the interviews
yeah you know again I think I think it's
all a matter of it's all a matter of
adjusting to what the of what the
environment is at any given moment and
adjusting in art of war kind of way I
don't think about in those terms but but
acknowledge what the terrain is and I
think a lot of what seems like in my
career in general as though I've had
this vision for how my career was going
to change and things I would try to do
and and to get things accomplished was
was more a reaction to what the
circumstances were so for example I
thought swingers would open a lot of
doors from the acting lines it didn't I
got to do a little bit of stuff here and
there it was fun but I was very sought
after as a writer after that and so the
writer door opened up the actor door was
you know kind of more of a more of a
small you know a little cracked open
door that occasionally I could poke my
nose through but it wasn't receiving me
but the but the writer door was wide
open so I started to do that and I
learned a lot about storytelling and
interacting with executives and what the
system was by being involved with
projects and none of which that ever got
actually produced with the versions that
I wrote but I was part of a chain of
writers on on certain projects so I
would I was pretty good at at adjusting
to what path was available to me and
finding something interesting about what
was available but without ever feeling I
was compromising but just trying to
check out something that could be cool
and not getting in my own way of saying
why shouldn't I be a writer on this why
not pitch this take on a movie even
though I've never done a rewrite why why
not go in there and talk to them about
this and and so I've had I think I've
had enough confidence to not be scared
to try something new which i think is
something I get in a lot of people's
ways I think people get in their own way
a lot and there's certain things that
I'm you know that I have been scared of
but but for some reason career-wise
maybe it's my early upbringing I don't
know what but I never feel intimidated
when I'm in a room with people or if I'm
on stage in front of people like I don't
I don't get that my heart doesn't
doesn't race in those situations even
before the improv
yeah I've always been comfortable like
getting in front of people and talking
and I've been a bit of a hand when I was
little like loving that jump up in front
of the family and put on shows I just
think certain people wired now that I
have three kids for sure you just kind
of wired a certain way and certain
people are you know kind of you know
they kind of have certain things that
they like and certain things that
they're good at and you could adjust
them and change them but you're kind of
kind of working with huh you know you're
kind of handed it's like it's like poker
you get it you know you get dealt a hand
and you could play those cards well or
poorly but but you're definitely working
from
you know you're definitely inheriting
your properties in risk at the beginning
of the game you know what I mean you're
you're you're starting from a certain
vantage point and then and then it's
what do you do with that with with the
movie like swingers for instance and
again this is these are just things that
I've heard quoted so feel free to
correct me if I'm wrong it's it seems
like everyone has seen swingers I mean
it gets it gets quoted all the time
the box office was around six million it
was yeah if that if that so it was
considered you know so so just to give
you a perspective we you know trying to
get it made for a year nobody gives us
the money Doug Liman was able to raise
the money and we make it together what
is his he's a director that's the
director of the film but when I had met
him I was trying to set it up as a
director I was trying to direct it and
he had already done a film he was just
part of a circle of friends and not very
I wasn't very close with him but I knew
him through somebody else and he was
somebody who had directed and so I had
you know bought him a cup of coffee he
talked me through lenses and was
preparing me for when it was time for me
to direct and then in that process had
said look I know you you know hopefully
you will get to put this thing together
but but I can raise the money and and so
we agreed to creatively be partners on
this thing and and and we made it a much
smaller budget than I thought was
possible
this was the 200 kids person 200 care
that he was able to bring and figure out
how to bring that movie to the screen
with that budget with the experience
that he had had so so that it happened
we tried to get into Sundance and not
into but was he that financing from some
independently wealthy individuals or was
it from yeah a company it was more like
that yeah I think it was more of the
connections that he had from growing up
in town and being involved with you know
there are people that he knew that were
willing to bet on him as some of it was
based on stuff he had done already and
some of it was um you know that he you
know I passionate about this thing but
he was able to get the the secure the
financing got it so so the first
experience was that then then we made it
and that was real seat-of-the-pants
and then we didn't get into Sundance
which was our goal was to get in that
was the be-all and end-all for us and I
don't know if it was that it wasn't
finished enough or we had just just
pulled it you know cut together for them
or it was screened on videotape versus a
screening who knows what it was was
incredibly disappointing us so I felt
like all was lost then we put up after
Sunday at Sundance festival when
everybody had gotten back we had done
our own screening in Los Angeles for the
cast and crew and invited some
distributors to it as well and it played
extraordinary or extraordinarily well
there and then we had multiple buyers
and you know you don't have to be in
Hollywood to know what that means you
know more than one person it is
interested it's a whole different
dynamic and now there was a bit of a
bidding war over and ended up selling
for five million dollars and there's a
distribution or a distribution rights
and and so we were we were riding high
it was you know and all the all everyone
wants to interview us and everybody
wanted to feature us in their magazines
and we were like the next thing and and
so unlike the year between when it was
acquired and when it came out we were
riding very high Vincent I think got
cast in the sequel to Jurassic Park
which is about as big as you can get and
everybody who was nobody was now had a
seat at the table had another shot you
know and and then by the time the movie
came out it opened first weekend is in
whatever two theaters for theaters it
was huge box office and then a few weeks
later nobody cared
and it made five million dollars and and
it was considered a failure yet the box
office wise because you got to figure on
one side of us was like Slingblade that
made a hundred million dollars and won
Oscars on the other side was Good Will
Hunting that won Oscars I made like
hundred my dollars so we were kind of
the disappointing underperformer at
Miramax at that point and so all of it
kind of ebb away but again it was it was
enough to get my foot in the door as a
writer and I had already now I had not
just been the guy who was in
Rudie as a character actor but now I
been in this movie that as you said
everybody has seen so thanks to video
and later DVD and earlier on laserdisc
everybody had seen this film and it
become part of our culture and that's
when I kind of learned that it's not
always the movie that does the best that
has the most impact or is the most
rewarding or does the most for your
career for that matter even though in
the short term success is is celebrated
here and failure is unforgivable
but over time I think that it that
shifts a bit and I know for example like
Vince had got in Jurassic Park on the
heels of swingers he's far more
recognized now from swingers that
grossed one you know not even a tenth
maybe a hundredth of what that movie
made but for some reason this one has
had more impact on his career even
though far less people went to see it in
the movie theater so you never know
what's gonna and I and I find in my own
career the same thing it's not always
the things that make the most money it's
the things that the performances were
there's something about certain projects
that stick in people's memories more
yeah the staying power you know I was I
was astonished as I started studying
film more and looking at movies that had
a huge impact on me or were these
landmark iconic films among the you know
high school and college males who were
the majority of my friends in Fight Club
for instance and I was astonished that
it wasn't some yes of massive aging bull
you know was you know all these movies
that are sort of failures in the in the
in the in the beginning and more Rudy
was my first experience with a movie
coming out it didn't do well and I'll do
a new number one at the box office was
considered also an underperformer but
now everybody knows it it's a cultural
you know that it's it's a cultural point
of reference I hear the music everywhere
I people refer to it constantly so like
those are the ones where you make the
ripple the cultural ripple and that's
honestly the thing that's is most
exciting that that's the most appealing
to me is how can you impact how can you
make that kind of impact and affect
people and either touch them and
tain them make them laugh make them feel
connected you know that's the that's the
part that's the most rewarding at this
point in my career and I am keeping an
eye on the time I know that even very
generous with your time and I'll I'll
only take a few more minutes
the I would be remiss of me if I didn't
mention that a number of my fans have
said to thank you for chef they've
rented it five to ten times just to show
friends so I think that that I think
that's gonna be one of the movies I
think is what that's really what that's
was kind of the thing I know with with
in like the the chef community they
accepted it the ones that I've met so
that was a big scary part of it for me
because if everybody if people had like
to who didn't know about that world and
but then the people who are in the world
didn't like it it would have been mixed
they went to felt good to me but the
fact that people are seeing it now like
I I'm spending more time with my son
after seeing the movie or you know what
I'm going to try to open up my own
business that I've been putting off
forever and that's when you feel really
humbled and good and flattered because
you feel like you're connecting it's
selfishly just a very good feeling to
know that that you're that year you're
me being on this planet has changed
somebody else's experience like in a
good way
and it feels it feels them it feels you
feel connected to people which i think
is kind of part of the the trip here
that's part kind of part of the goal not
for sure well I think anything with a
basis and storytelling at some point I
mean you're making a lot of connections
through this I think there's we are
hard-wired for this this Joseph Campbell
like experience even to our own lives
I'd love to ask just a couple of
rapid-fire questions sure the first is
when you hear the word successful who is
the first person who comes to mind
Wow oh I like listening to this on your
show I don't like answering it
um let's see I guess I just need your
these are gates okay and not beat you
know why because because um not because
of the richest guy but because of his
because of how he shifted his his
priorities because he's now making
tremendous impact with the hand he's
been dealt or the the pot that he's
built up that he's making that there's
one there's like there's like the Bill
Gates from this the Microsoft Bill Gates
and there's the post Microsoft Bill
Gates and and to me there's something
fascinating about that and that he was
being able to be effective in what his
goals were for the first chapter and
then what his goals are now which are
very different so he was able to shift
his entire shift his entire agenda and
and and be effective be completely
effective and yeah in this area similar
metric driven hardcore approach and I
don't know a lot about honestly about
this is purely layman's perspective of
hey there's a lot of this is how many
lives have been saved by this or this is
the this many people have agreed to have
charitable donations but it's just uh
there's something that the he's is the
first name that popped in my head
any particular director who comes to
mind director or writer and um there's a
few you know and they're all different
like I worked with Scorsese and I think
that he's been I think there's a certain
there must be when I came up and what he
represented and I got to meet with him
and see him work and so he's inspired me
as far as what his body of work and and
who he is as a person but I also think
of like the Coen brothers who've managed
to tickle their own fancy and enjoy
everything they're doing and have
tremendous variety and
entertain people as well but seemed to
have maintained a certain balance a
healthy balance between their work and
and and their private lives and they
haven't dealt with them that much but
they seem like genuinely like
well-adjusted normal nice people who
happen to make really exciting cool
movies and then Jim Cameron who's sort
of the other end of the spectrum who's
kind of the guy who's reinvented aspects
of the industry over and over again with
tremendous enthusiasm and and and and
also just a sharp intellect that's into
solving problems and changing the way we
do the magic tricks and and I'm sure
I've certainly inherited a lot of what
he of the ground that he broke with
avatar with Jungle Book a lot of the
same technology a lot of same people I'm
working with so there's a you know a
healthy respect and then Walt Disney is
another one who I had researched quite a
bit back around the time of Ironman -
when we were referencing him in a in the
stark Expo and the stark the old stark
archives but he was a bit of a techie at
his time and a bit of a storyteller -
and so he was doing the you know what he
was doing at his time is like this seems
like what Pixar's doing now it's like
cutting edge technology great stories
great emotion telling stories of the
difference of the tools that nobody ever
had before and there's something there's
something really to me I think he was
he's one of those key figures oh total
hacker they display a bunch of his old
cobbled together MacGyver like rigs at
the Disney Family museum in San
Francisco Presidio yeah which is amazing
what is the book that you've gifted the
most to other people actually the
writers journey was one of them I've
given your book I've given for our body
the people thank you for that I've given
that those did the biggies I'm trying to
think it was anything else hmm
I did grow when I first start off in
acting i gifted Grodin's book to my
family
his first book it would be so nice if
you weren't here because it really told
the story about how difficult it is when
you're first starting off trying to be
an actor and he had such a great voice
other than that I can't not not our
jumping jumping to mind
that's three though that's funny that's
plenty
last question actually they're two
they're pretty quick but first is what
advice would you give to your 20 year
old self listen up 30 year old self I
think to not confuse how you feel about
something with how that thing really is
I think you think you're being more
objective than you really are and you're
colored by emotion more than you think
you are in in positive ways and negative
ways but but it some perspective is is
much more subjective than you think you
think you're a lot more objective and
than you are to me specifically at 30
and 20 I don't even know how wasn't even
a human being what I would say it's
funny because it's part of it is just
the ignorance of walking into you know
the the forest and not knowing where I
was going and whatever was getting me
through it you know thank thankfully I
had enough something in the back of my
mind told me to just take that road and
walk not knowing where I was going and
so that was um so I'm very grateful I
like where I am I like what the
experience of my life is I like every
year I like better I like Who I am
better I like what my life is better so
it I'm very reluctant to interfere with
the way things were but I think a lot of
us how I feel about things and what I do
to kind of balance things out in a way
that is is that I'm proud of that I like
well I love your work and thank you so
much for the time where can people find
out
more about you find you online hey let's
see I don't know I I'm on a Twitter and
Facebook at John underscore Favreau on
Twitter and then Facebook I think is
just John Favreau and Instagram Jon
Favreau it's pretty pretty cool system
they'd been working so there's not a lot
of stuff up there you know we'll I'm on
there what we do like we do pop-ups once
in a while in Los Angeles maybe we'll do
one up north for the from the food from
Chateau that'd be great so we I believe
been doing that business dying to have I
think not only Cuban but the grilled
cheese sandwich I'm sure you must hear
about that a lot yes I've cooked them I
cooked them for the crew of the movie I
cook them for my kids I cook them here
at the in the editing rooms but I enjoy
cooking we've cooked together I think we
reveal that that we definitely I have
cooked cooked beignets than is that was
an amazing experience for so good you
had never done the before I was that was
what we're talking about yeah we were we
we didn't really know each other that
well I read your stuff you saw my stuff
and then lo and behold you put some some
hot oil there and the focus is no longer
on one another thank you say your
fingers out he's called it keeping all
your fingers well John thank you so much
there's there's tons more to explore
everybody I'll put links in the show
notes to where you could find John and
thanks so much roots all right great and
thank you too I love I love the podcast
but I you've I know this was about me
not about you but I got to know you
through your writing and I was very
you're very uh intriguing I get pulled
into your work you make it very easy to
read your stuff it had been recommended
I think for our body was recommended to
me and one of those things you just pick
a chapter here chapter there next thing
you know you reading the whole thing and
your approach to questioning things and
curating research and fact-based but not
being you know it seems like there's
always you always are either dealing
with a scientific method where something
has to have been through a double-blind
study or a completely anecdotal there's
there was no middle ground of what's
interesting about about your stuff is
you'll say hey look here's what I've
experienced here's the sample that I've
seen this experience with it's not some
that should be looked at scientifically
but there are certain indications that
this is worth looking into more and
here's what I do and here's what I've
done and it makes it much more inviting
than either the very walled off world of
traditional academia academia and then
also this I don't know science that's
more based on anecdotal information that
doesn't take science into consideration
as much but to acknowledge that science
has an importance to it but also looking
at how what has not yet gone through
that machine might have some truth to it
too and giving full disclosure of your
context and why makes it not
intellectually offensive could be
responsible intellectually not flying in
the face of science but but you're also
opening it up to new ways of thinking
and and you know I think it relates to
the way your context the whole world
that you're the whole Northern
California way of eCos of looking at
things and how to how to be more
effective and efficient in in
approaching problems that we still face
so I love looking your stuff and like I
say thank you the three the 4-hour chef
was really was a great counterbalance to
the other chef biographies that I was
reading or autobiographies or cooking
books and documentaries I was watching
and then here was the very concise
version of a lot of the same information
there was a really good really good
counterbalance well I I really
appreciate it and I love watching your
experiments I love watching you do the
the huge blockbusters then do chef I
can't wait to see what you do next well
I know if I guess I'm waiting to see
Uncle Buck jungle book right here it's
gonna be amazing it's gonna be something
different and cool and you know just
like everything else the doing doing one
with this level of technology which I
you know I got a taste of here and there
with Iron Man and but to really throw
the throw the whole thing into you have
the whole movie rely on that magic trick
working is
it's it's um exhilarating but if it all
works as well as it looks like it will
its it'll be something nobody had seen
before so it's it's exciting stuff I
can't wait to see it will John
to be continued thank you so much for
the time right my pleasure and this is
fun it's quick and easy quick and easy
alright alright thanks thank you
the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you
by on it I have used on it products for
years if you look in my kitchen in my
garage you will find alpha brain
chewable melatonin for resetting my
clock when I'm traveling kettlebells
battle ropes maces steel clubs
sounds like a torture chamber and it
kind of is it's a torture chamber for
self-improvement and you can see all of
my favorite gear at on it com forward
slash Tim that's onn IT comm forward
slash Tim and you can also get a
discount on any supplements food
products I like hemp force I like alpha
bran check it all out on it comm forward
slash Tim the Tim Ferriss show is also
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
your one-stop shop for anything graphic
design related you need a logo you need
a website you need a business card or
anything else you get an original design
from designers around the world who
submit drafts for you to review you are
happy or you get your money back and I
have used 99 designs for book cover
ideas for the 4-hour body which went to
number one New York Times for banner ads
and you can check out some of my actual
competitions at 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim you can also get a
free $99 upgrade if you want to give it
a shot that's 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim and until next time thanks for
listening